todo lo que hemos visto hasta el momento
involucra a sistemas de ecuaciones y lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
analizar sistemas de ecuaciones lineales
que tienen desigualdades básicamente lo
que vamos a hacer es encontrar todos los
puntos en este plano cartesiano que
satisfacen a todas las ecuaciones de
este sistema de ecuaciones lineales con
desigualdades así que vamos a empezar
con nuestra primera ecuación lineal con
desigualdad es 2x menos 3 james menor o
igual que 21 y ya hemos visto
anteriormente cómo graficar este tipo de
ecuaciones primero vemos cuáles son los
puntos que componen esta línea de acá y
después encontramos qué significa esta
parte de menor o igual que lo primero
que hacemos es restar 2x a ambos lados
de esta ecuación menos 2x hacemos la
operación aquí nos queda menos
quitamos 2x menor o igual a menos 2 x +
21 y ahora vamos a dividir ambos lados
por menos 3 ojo acuérdense que cuando
dividimos por un número negativo nuestra
igualdad o nuestra desigualdad se va a
cambiar se va a invertir así que aquí
nos va a quedar menos 3 y entre menos 3
mayor o igual a menos 2 entre menos 3 x
más 21 entre menos 3 y esto queda ya
mayor o igual que 2 entre 3 x menos 7
menos 7 y esta es nuestra primera
desigualdad
y ahora vamos a graficar la en color
naranja aquí pone a este punto ponemos
este punto menos 7 y ahora vamos a
graficar los siguientes puntos
contamos 3 a la derecha 2 arriba 3 a la
derecha 2 arriba 3 a la derecha 2 arriba
si queremos graficar de este otro lado
van a ser 3 a la izquierda 2 abajo y
aquí vamos a dibujar esta línea nos va a
quedar más o menos así continúa por acá
y ya que los valores de y deben ser
mayor o igual que esta línea de acá el
área que satisface esta desigualdad va a
estar por encima de esta línea
incluyendo la línea ya que son mayor o
igual así que todos los valores de jay
que cumplen esta desigualdad van a estar
por encima de esta línea así que con
sólo indicar esta restricción de que
debe ser mayor o igual que 2 entre 3 x
menos 7 oeste de aquí que es lo mismo 2
x 3
ahora igual a 21 nos van a dar toda esta
área que voy a estar sombreando aquí voy
a estar la sombra no muy suavecito al
menos ahorita con este color naranja y
ahora vamos a agregar otra desigualdad a
nuestra mezcla vamos a elegir otro color
x + 4 y vamos a hacer la menor que 6 en
lugar de menor o igual sólo va a ser
menor aquí vamos a tener ecuaciones con
desigualdad menor o igual o mayor o
igual o menor simplemente para
acordarnos cómo se hacen estas
ecuaciones vamos a restar menos x en
ambos lados de la desigualdad y nos
queda 4 y menor que menos x + 6 no
dividimos entre 4 ambos lados y nos
quedan 4 y entre 4 menos x entre 4 664
quedando ye menor que menos un cuarto de
x + 6 y ahora del mismo modo que lo
hicimos con la ecuación anterior vamos a
graficar esta línea
es más 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 aquí ponemos el punto y
después la pendiente va a ser menos 1 /
4 así que son 1 2 3 4 y abajo 1 4 a la
derecha 1 2 3 4 abajo 1 1 2 3 4 a la
derecha abajo 1 y parece que esta línea
se nos está saliendo del espacio ahora
de este otro lado van a ser 1 2 3 4 a la
izquierda 1 arriba y como esta parte no
incluye la igualdad vamos a escribir
esta línea como una línea punteada ya
que los valores de 10 son menores pero
no iguales a los de esta línea y de
hecho voy a extender la línea anterior
para que se note en donde se intersectan
ambas y de nuevo les recuerdo que esta
es una línea punteada porque la ecuación
dice que es menor pero no llega a ser
igual a esta línea si yo graficar a esta
desigualdad sería el área debajo de la
línea sin incluir la aquí está el área
por debajo
debajo de esta línea aquí y eso es lo
que satisface esta desigualdad los
valores de ye que satisface esta
desigualdad están por debajo de esta
línea ahora si yo les fuera a preguntar
bueno tenemos 2x menos 3 menor o igual a
21 y otra ecuación o desigualdad de
hecho es seria
1 x + 4 y menor que 6 si yo les pidiera
que valores de xy satisfacción a ambas
desigualdades bueno ustedes rápidamente
me van a decir ah pues es el área que se
traslapa de las dos soluciones
anteriores el área que está por encima
de la línea naranja que es de esta
ecuación esta línea todos los valores de
ye que están por encima incluyendo la
línea naranja de esta ecuación y el área
que se encuentra por debajo del área
punteada que se encuentra en azul así
que esto que se traslapa lo estoy
subrayando o indicando en color amarillo
y ahora qué pasaría si por pura
diversión agregara una tercera ecuación
a este conjunto esta ecuación la voy a
poner de color verde y va a ser
es x más y va a ser mayor o igual que
menos 4 y es mayor o igual que menos 3 x
menos 4 lo único que hice fue restar
menos 13 x en ambos lados y vamos a
graficar esto menos 4 aquí y su
pendiente va a ser de menos tres así que
cada vez que vamos uno a la derecha
vamos a bajar 3 una a la izquierda 3
hacia arriba y de este lado es una la
izquierda tres arriba 123 una a la
izquierda 123 arriba uno a la izquierda
123 arriba esto lo hacemos una vez más y
esta línea verde va a quedar más o menos
así
tratando de dibujar lo mejor que puedo
es una línea completa no está punteada
ya que es un mayor o igual quiere decir
que está incluyendo los valores que
están en la línea ahora para cada valor
de x que yo elija mckean el valor de
menos 3 x menos 4 me va a dar este valor
así que los valores que me interesa van
a estar por encima de esta línea vamos a
ponerlo más o menos aquí en este color y
finalmente alguien podría llegar y decir
me quiero que me muestres me graphic es
me indique es los valores en este plano
cartesiano que corresponden o que
cumplen con este sistema de
desigualdades pues muy sencillo voy a
poner todos los elementos que están por
encima de esta línea naranja que están
aquí y que los indicamos en
naranja que están por encima de esta
línea dos tercios de x siete aunque aquí
se ve un poquito diferente pero es la
misma ecuación todo lo que está por
encima de esta línea y todo lo que está
por debajo de esta línea azul sin
incluir lo que está en la línea y todo
lo que esté por encima de la línea verde
incluyendo lo de la línea verde así que
va a ser todo esto que se poniendo en
rosita y esto va a incluir este límite
de por acá también este otro límite de
acá y ya que tengo un menor que 6 aquí
voy a tener una línea punteada indicando
que no se incluyen esos puntos de la
línea espero que les haya sido útil